ja lieber Herr Kollege Locke ähm hier spricht 1.
kreisrat und Bezirksrat als 1.
Ante in der Kommunalpolitiker der AfD
äh sie haben gerade bemängelt
wir seien so gemein zu ihnen,
wir würden die guten Sitten
gegen die guten Sitten verstoßen,
würden die würde des hohen Hauses verletzen
und sie wünschen sich doch etwas mehr Kommunalpolitik
ähm jetzt hab ich durchaus auch fotobelege
wie sie Herr streibel
und auch der Herr Paul
sich bei der rede von Herrn Oskar atziker
über die Rede kann man sicherlich streiten,
weil wie sie sich alle 3 da vorne umgedreht haben äh
finden sie in ihrem
Verhalten eine Verletzung der würde des hohenhauses
und würden sie sich beim Plenum
und bei der Fraktion
und beim Herrn Arzt Sänger dafür entschuldigen,
dass sie nicht bei ihrer Zwischenbemerkung äh
fast ins Grinsen gekommen sind.
die Rede von Mein atzinger
war eine Beleidigung für dieses hohe Haus
und mehr muss ich dazu nicht sagen
und ich frag mich echt OB sie mit ihren Kollegen,
ja und ich und ich frag mich wirklich OB sie
im Kreis Tag und auch in den gemeine koalamenten
von Kartell Parteien
von Asyl und der gleichen
genauso herziehen wie sies.
dann sind auch ihre Kollegen in den
kommunal Parlamenten nicht zu beneiden.
die tun Mir leid,
dass sie sich mit ihnen
auch dann in einem Sitzungssaal
abgeben müssen.
vielen lieben Dank.